こんにちはダール弾寒くなってきましたね摩れ3そろそろジャケットを着ようと思い
ますそして中には
名こんにちははじめ社長ですはい頃なのでパソコン使ったことある人
はいうん
はい今画面ノックでてあげてくれた人ごめん見えねえ
すぎでパソコンを使ったことある人思うんですけどもパソコンってすごいんですよ
usb ケーブルを挿すこういうバスあるんですけども
ここに挿せばなんでをパソコンに読み込めるんでしょこれマウスなんですけどもこの
バースの usb をパソコンに挿せばこれでパート4を動かせますし
sd カードの写真とかどう読み取りたい時もあるゲーセンでになんかさせますうみこ
ベルギーもう世の中ですね10 sb が全てなんですそんな中でまぁ普通にパソコン
で usb ケーブル挿すと少ないんでこちらが重要になってくるわけですよ usb
ハブと言われるやってねまあすごいかなりで責めするとこれこれだと31個しか入れ
ないじゃんねってのこのハブを指すと1個しかなかった usb させところが
4つになるんですよ
すごくないですかつまり皆さん俺がないと usb 1個しかさせないんですよ
多分パパも使ってる人ならよく知ってるともネッけど他の牛 sb ハーブが本当必須
でパソコン作って人からするとここで例えば村付ハードディスクを足したり sd
カードリーダーを刺したりマウスを刺したりモニターにつなげたりスピーカー2基下げ
たり usb ハブってあればあるほど無限なんですよ
さあでわれ
usb させるところでどこまで増やせるのでしょうかと言われて今回東京の連続最
レベなんだまだベッチャーですよこれもう本当に何か買ったわからないから指たし買っ
ちゃったんですけど何個だの一つの usb ケーブルを4つにする奴を30回ました
というわけで旧は俺が作ってやるよ
世界で一番 usb ケーブル
させる早速史上最大量のゆず b テーブル
今が共感で振ると思われますただここで僕が不安などは指して指して指して指して指し
って言ったらなんかどんどん電力が弱まっていって最後方なんか usb させても
意味ないんじゃないか説明があるんで
ただしどれぐらいまで反応するのかというのもちょっと気になりますでは早速 usb
たく著
していきましたよでは早速最強に唯一にライブ活動をつくっていきましょう
フック減じるんね12でしょこれをさせだけってもわっっちょっと青くなるのはこれを
指すんだけでも午後になりました
多分めっちゃのビザの下にやりましょう
[音楽]
そしてこれだけだと思ったらもっとたくさんエネルギーましたーーー
なぁこになるのこれはこれは4つ入るかな
30125個ぐらい入ります
投げていきます
ん
[音楽]
tan
hyde 着で今10個繋いでみたんですけども突っ込めでも全然花勉強は通っており
ますさあ2明けで抵抗うじゃうじゃしてきたんですけどもどんどんつないでいき
ましょう
やっぱりなんかだんだん電力が弱まってきている気がします
ファンに実行となりましたまだ全然ですねー
電気は通っています
これああれやばい組ちゃったこれで4つ目に多大なる usb ハブでこっちが20個
明太で usb ハブなんですけども
見てきっかりの強さがもう違うめっちゃ良いもうこっちやっぱどんどん電力が弱くなっ
ているのか私何個かエース身幅繋げるんでしょうか
ちょっとして行く時つないでいこうと思います
まあ記念すべき30個目ですはいうわぁ
ああいいいいいいだなやっち
+ね
ここまできたらもうやめられねぇため1回ちょっと限界まで40個1000円みようと
思いますどこがどうだ
ん
はいという40個目でまずそもそもこの40個目が点灯するのが動画ですね
今
買ってるあっ光ってる光ってる光ってる4つ目の光と比べるともうほんと小さいね同じ
やって使っても4個目と4ず米こんなに光の差が出ることが分かりました
さあそういうわけで私は今100ロレ格ゲー中9 usb ケーブルをさせる視聴最強
パソコンを作り上げてしまったただここに大事なのはちゃんと
その usb ケーブルに何かを指して動くかどうかそこで一番わかりやすいものとし
てまーす早速40個目にさせてみようと思う
これ動かなかったり意味ないから40コミック誌等でた島
はい近く比較赤外線で見ずらいと思いますねちょ叱ってます今回して僕の鼻の穴に
合わせているんですけども動くのかどうか
やってみましょう
今
青いって
うわぁ
フク子がん
me
teame
car
me up
なんでや
ちなみにまーすって何込めて動くようになるでしょうかそれだけちょっと実験してみ
ます
1個目
動く動く2個目
動く全然ごくごく3個目
動く動く動く4個目
お米
オーグ6個目
わー
6個目から動かなくなりますね意外とダメだ
ななこねー
まあ誰だもう5個死ねる usb ハブここまで近く動かないでこれ直れでなんで
ちょっと並列でやってみますか
たいというで一応末端の usb ハブ以外は全部に恋調布 usb 化させるように
並列な配列にしてみました
お金米の形電力の供給がどう変化するかわかんないんですけどもいけないとまずさせて
みましょう
結構
圧縮したからどこでもいいかも気がすんだよ
ずつ名
あここだけだった3つ目
4すげー圧縮すると3つでも置かないわ
結果 usb はだいたい4つまで